<今から私が話すことは>
<私が>
<ここ最近で 体験した>
<本当にあった 出来事です>
うわっ！
はぁっはぁっ　もう…
<彼の名前は>
<いながきたかまさ>
(はじめ)びっくりした　お前何やってんのこんなとこで
<僕たちは 彼のことを>
<「たて面」と 呼んでいます>
<いつからでしょうか>
<どこで出会ったかも>
<覚えていません>
<ですが>
<気付いた時には>
<なぜか>
<私の家に 出入りするようになっていました>
<しばらく 彼といて>
<わかったことがあります>
<あの男は>
<変だ>
<あれは>
<私が動画編集をしていた時のことです>
<ふと>
<後ろを見た時のことでした>
ああーーーっ　つっかれたぁーーー…
うわぁっ！？
おっ　編集頑張ってますね！
お前いつからいたんだよ！
てか近っ！
ｗｗ　そうですかぁ？
近いよ
びっくりしたぁ
そんなことないっスよｗｗ
いや近いよ〜〜
そうですかねぇ？あはは
っはははは
はははははは
<他の後輩と 3人で>
<夜ご飯を>
<どこに食べにいこうかという話をしていた>
<時のことです>
(けんすけ)牛丼？
牛丼ありだな〜
たて面は？
たて面？
たて面！？
<返事が>
<返ってきませんでした>
たて面！
ほぇっ
外見てましたｗ
っははは
はははは
いやもう全然気付かなくってｗ
ははははは
はははぁぐぁぐ
<私が>
<1人でゲームをしていた時>
<突然彼から LINEが届きました>
っしぃぃぃぃ……
<彼は>
<5時間経っても>
<来ることはありませんでした>
遅っ！
<私は心配になり>
ええ！？　遅っ
<彼に電話をしてみました>
あ もしもし？
たて面「あ　はい！もしもし」
何やってんのぉ？
たて面「え　何がですか？」
え　来るって言ってなかった？
たて面「そうですかぁ？ｗｗｗ」
たて面「すいませんｗｗｗ」
たて面「忘れてましたｗｗｗ」
忘れてたのぉ？
たて面「そうだった そうだった すいませんｗｗ」
たて面「ごめんなさい すぐ行きますねｗｗ」
ああ わ　わかった…
たて面「ごめんなさいｗｗ」
ああ　いいえ…
たて面「ｗｗ　ごめんなｓ」
[ﾋﾟﾛﾝ](LINE電話切る音)
[ﾄﾞﾝ ﾄﾞﾝ ﾄﾞﾝ]
[ｶﾞﾁｬｯ]
ごめんなさい！　遅れました！
ハッ……ハハハハハ
ハッハッアフアフア
アフアフアフアフア
<あれは>
<みんなで お菓子を食べながら>
<喋っていた時の出来事です>
(はじめ)すごいよねぇ？
(けんすけ)すごすぎるほんとに
(はじめ)オレは出来んわ さすがに
(けんすけ)天才だよ
(たて面)ほんとにもう　◎△＄♪ましたよねオレもｗｗ
(たて面)はっはっはっはっは
(けんすけ)すごすぎる すごすぎる
教えて欲しい↑
食べやがったなぁ？
けんすけ
1本だけだよ
もうオレ これ誰にもあげる気ないから
もうあげないかんね もう
食べていいっスかぁ？
[ﾎﾟﾘﾎﾟﾘ]
おほほっｗｗｗ
[ｽﾝｯ ｽﾝｯ](鼻をすする)
ははｗ　え？
はははｗｗｗ
ははｗｗ　[ﾎﾟﾘﾎﾟﾘ]
どうしたんスかぁ？フフｗ
フフフ
ははっ
はははっ
ハハハハハｗｗｗｗ
ハハハハハ
<そして>
<最も恐ろしい出来事が>
<このあと起きたのです>
たてめーん
たて面
◎△＄♪×￥●＆％＃
！＃＆”＝％0＝＄＆
＝！＃＆￥●％＃＞
＊＋』＆（＃0〜＝＆’〜｜
えあぴるｇ：３ー「お＠いｊｖげあｒ：ｋｇｍｖ；；
<私の170万円の財布の>
<クルクルするところを>
<永遠に>
<回していたのです>
オイ！　何やってんのお前！！これ…
オレのさぁ！170万の財布じゃん！
えっ？　はじめさんのだったんスか？
いやオレのだよぉ！！
っハハハハハｗｗｗ
えっ？ｗｗｗ
めっちゃクルクルしてたじゃん！
クルクルしやすいですよねｗｗｗｗ
なんで！？
緩くなんじゃん これさぁーー
ごめんなさい ごめんなさいｗｗｗ
大丈夫っス 大丈夫っスｗｗｗ
何でほんとにさぁーーーもぉーーー
ごめんなさいｗｗｗｗ
アッ　アハハハハ
アファアファアファ
アハハハ…(エコー)
[恐怖系ED]